good morning John I just got back home
to Missoula Oh from tour and I thought I
might be pissed a to share with you one
full day even the life of the tour what
it's like on the road so here we go
lord wake up super early at the board
except to put on your awesome new belt
buckle f3 everything no matter how
disgusting goes in one bag 3 van Tetris
step 6
go exploring step 9
breakfast step nine point five car
breakfast ten through 800 and sit in the
van Andrews in there somewhere
eyeball the shape this is the part of
the day where we try to get Ethiopian
food but it's closed and now we're in a
parking lot and it's a thousand degrees
Kelvin now I have to pee step 3 arrive
at the venue and comment on how it's
different from other venues you play
that so they haven't been like this for
the most part I mean I don't want to
tell you what kind of bathrooms I've
been spending time in but they're not
like this one you get a riser today yeah
that was the part where Rob Scallon
plays me a personal concert so I missed
the step where we load everything into
the venue I feel bad about that I don't
know where I was I had to do something I
was on a funk of step 32 set up the
merch stand step 35
give me my VIP bracelet whatever the
sparkles made of platinum this is the
green room which is purple here you know
this is a nice green room because I have
not seen a single piece of pornographic
graffiti dude what are we doing now 63
fog machine step negative 8 dinner
shirt step 25 P a bunch of different
times before we go on stage this is the
part I hate the most is the waiting to
go on stage there was pony club just
finished I can tell because of how wet
Sam is a lot Hey coupon 3gu part 83 -
your hair in your camera before you go
on stage part 84 go on stage
part 6080 to finish the show oh oh
that's nice whoa part eight million
I'm going out to sign and take pictures
with people step 94 get to the hotel
realize that you're starving and try and
figure out a place to eat step ninety
eight goof around step ninety three
second a nerd just not Andrew how to
take off his VIP wrist bracelet during
which process he karate-chopped his beer
on to me that's to fall asleep in the
fan again stepford to go to bed at a
do-over get aborting John let's see you
on Tuesday